c'est l'heure du second débat de ce sens
public consacré aux enjeux des élections
sénatoriales je crois que c'est le
meilleur endroit pour le pour le faire
on est bien d'accord elle se déroule le
24 septembre prochain des élections un
peu particulières puisque nous n'irons
pas voter nous citoyens ce sont de
grands électeurs essentiellement des
élus qui désigneront les nouveaux
sénateurs et sénatrices des règles
différentes mais une campagne électorale
intense la preuve avec ce reportage
d'audre buetaz et Jonathan Dupriez en
nizè une rencontre à peine terminée bon
c'était très bien Thierry cette cette
réunion va bien passé et il faut déjà
pour Michel Savin et Frédéric puissat
mettre le cap sur la suivante allez on a
calé 55 journées depuis le 11 juin avec
C rayons par jour on a beaucoup de Maes
qui qui n'arriveraient pas à s'exprimer
dans des grandes réunions et là dans des
petites réunions on est chez eux la
parole est plus facile à recueillir pour
tenter de convaincre les grands
électeurs ils vont visiter 275 communes
dans une voiture transformée en bureau t
les jours quand on part on a une fiche
on est organisé on sait ce qu'on va
faire des kilomètres de route sûr que
c'était là ou c'est ça avec un objectif
pour le duo LR sortant être réélu tous
les deux il y a 5 siège à pourvoir en
iser la répartition se fait à la
proportionnelle en fonction des scores
obtenus par chaque liste si on fait
cette campagne d'aller rencontrer
d'essayer de rencontrer le maximum de
grands électeurs c'est bien qu'on n pas
la prétention de dire est sûr d'être élu
et après on verra le score des des
différentes listes leur avantage ils
peuvent défendre un bilan et compter sur
le soutien de la région et du
département à droite leur point faible
plusieurs grosses communes ont basculé à
gauche en 2020 mais ce n'est pas tout
face à eux l'écologiste Guillaume
Gontard vient de réussir un petit
exploit unir plusieurs forces de gauche
bien cette campagne bah ouais ça se
passe bien ou derrière lui il y a la
communiste Frédéric penaver et et le
socialiste Erwan Binet par ce que les
élus attendent c'est de la
responsabilité de la responsabilité dans
une période qui est complexe sur lequel
on a besoin de peser besoin de peser au
Sénat besoin de renforcer le pôle
écologiste et de gauche au Sénat et on a
actuellement 92 parlementaires de gauche
et écologiste nous notre ambition c'est
de de faire passer au-delà de de 100 et
donc voilà moi c'est ça qui m'anime et
c'est ça qui m'anime avec l'ensemble de
mes colistières et colistiers même si
tout le monde en convient les chances de
gagner trois sièges à gauche sont
extrêmement minces d'autant que Jean y
Bron salut toi le maire de l'erieux au
nord du département se présente en
dissident alors apparemment on a la
deuxième manche ouais on est en train de
perdre c'est vrai certains y voient un
match à distance entre Christophe
Ferrari le président socialiste de la
métropole grenobloise qui le soutient et
Éric Piol le maire écologiste de
Grenoble qui soutient l'autre liste mais
jean- y Brunier s'en défend s'il y avait
eu des oppositions local qui était à
l'initiative finalement de cette liste
Christophe Ferrari serait premier de la
liste le fait de pouvoir construire
cette proposition alternative c'est
surtout le fruit d'un travail collectif
parce qu'on a aussi estimé qu'il était
nécessaire que toute l'isè soi
représenté et on sent bien qu'il y a un
manque de représentation au niveau
sénatorial dans le nordisire un
éparpiement des voix qui pourrait aider
Didier rambau sénateur de la majorité
présidentielle bonjour il pâtit dans
cette campagne des liens distendus entre
Emmanuel Macron et les élus je vais pas
me me cacher tout le monde le sait hein
voilà j'étais en iser le le premier
partant derrière Emmanuel Macron le
premier marcheur comme comme on dit donc
voilà je v pas pas me me défiler
oui c'est clair que j'ai pas le vent
dans le dos comme on dit mais bon les
élus locaux le savent mais je pense
qu'ils ont aussi besoin parmi les se les
cinq sénateurs d'avoir un sénateur de la
majorité présidentielle de son handicap
il tente donc de faire une force à la
différence de ses opposants il a selon
lui l'oreille du président pour faire
Remon les problématiques iszerroises un
atout précieux qui pourrait peut-être le
IC vers un second mandat voilà il
pourrait être complet sur ces élections
sénateor en nzer la liste des candidats
donc union de la droite conduite par
Michel Savin union des gauches Guillaume
Gontard majorité présidentielle on l' vu
dier Rambo France insoumise Alban Rossa
reconquête Gérard danzepte et divers
gauche jean-y brgier les enjeux de ces
élections sénatoriales on en débat tout
de suite avec lucide Schmith bonsoir
bonsoir bienvenue heureux de vous
accueillir vous êtes vice-présidente du
cercle de réflexion la fabrique
écologique et auteur de ce livre
Emmanuel Macron à contetemps paru aux
éditions Bayard Benjamin Morel bonsoir
bienvenue à vous constitutionnaliste
maître de conférence en droit public à
Paris de Panthéon Assas Stéphane Vernet
bonsoir bonsoir bienvenue à vous vous
êtes journaliste rédacteur en chef
délégué directeur de la rédaction de
West France à Paris auteur de ce livre
déjeuner secret dans les coulisses de la
réforme des retraites qui paraît demain
ce vendredi aux éditions West France Tam
tranui est évidemment rester à mes côtés
éctoraliste politique une campagne
électorale une campagne sénatoriale
lucide schmi vous vous connaissez vous
avez été élu local dans les hautes
scènes si si je ne me trompe donc grande
électrice comment ça se pas vous voyez
défiler tous les candidats on est c'est
un processus de séduction permanent qu
c'est c'est c'est quoi le ce qui est
très intéressant et très surprenant
quand on est habitué à à voter comme un
électeur anonyme c'est jquement on
devient une personne importante on ne
l'avait pas réalisé mais on l'est parce
que au fond comme vous le dites c'est un
petit milieu où chacun peut
individuellement enfin en tout cas on
peut essayer individuellement d'aller
voir les grands électeurs et du coup
cette question des camps respectifs
cétait frappant de voir ce ce marcheur
qui disait au fond voilà est-ce que
Emmanuel Macron a suffisamment chouchoué
les élus locaux la question de la
relation personnelle est très forte
alors que lorsqu'on vote pour les
législatives la question de l'anonymat
est très forte c'està-dire que on vote
pour des affiches pour des des personnes
abstraites tandis que quand on vote au
sénatorial on vote parfois et même assez
souvent pour des personnes que l'on
connaît où on choisit de ne pas voter
pour des personnes que l'on déteste et
ça c'est important parce que vous savez
qu'en politique la question des
relations interpersonnel est compliqué
il y a pas que là mais c'est quand même
parfois d'une grande violence ou d'une
d'une grande affection fininte et comme
le vote est secret vous pouvez avoir de
très nombreuses surprises ce qui moi
m'avait dans les hautes scènes m'avait
beaucoup intéressé c'est que par exemple
pour lutter contre la parité
obligatoire donc dans les listes à la
proportionnelle un certain nombre de
listes était apparu avec chaque fois un
homme en tête de liste ils avaient
toujours trouvé des femmes pour être
deuxiè mais on savait que le seul qui
serait élu ce serait un homme et donc il
a il y a très régulièrement c'est dit là
aussi des dissidents des listes
dissidentes aux élections sénatoriales
ce qui traduit comment dirais-je d'abord
la frustration de ne pas avoir été
désigné de pas pouvoir être élu et
ensuite la possibilité de penser qu'on
va tourner le système grâce à la
relation interpersonnelle ben question
que tous les journalistes de Public
Sénat ont interdiction de poser c'est
laalinéa 12 BISAT je blague mais à quoi
sert le Sénat non non non je voulais
faire une blague pour démarrer je va me
coûter très très cher cette blague je
suis complètement fou non mais
sérieusement ce ce
bicamérisme ce bicamérisme c'est c'est
quand même un un pilier essentiel de nos
démocraties il y a pas que la France qui
qui qui a deux assemblées expliquez-nous
ça depuis quand ça dure le bicamérisme
alors le bicamérisme en réalité ça né
essentiellement sous la révolution à
l'époque on va considérer notamment sous
le Directoire et ben que une seule
chambre ça peut-être dangereux que les
emportements d'une d'une seule chambre
et ben peuvent conduire au chaos et
cetera et donc une chambre qui serait
une chambre de tempérament va apparaître
comme étant nécessaire on va retrouver
cette chambre ensuite tout au cours du
19e siècle hein avec quelques éclipses
notamment sous la 2e République mais
l'idée qu'il y aurait une seconde
Assemblée censée modérer les ardeurs de
la première et censée représenter à la
fois le peuple mais le représenter selon
un angle un peu différent un peuple plus
territorialisé c'est le principe du
Sénat de la République et ben ça va
conduire à justement conserver cette
seconde chambre on élit la moitié du
Sénat cette année ou on nlit pas
l'entièreté du Sénat pourquoi est-ce
qu'on en élique la moitié bah parce
qu'on considère que justement renouveler
l'ensemble du Sénat en une fois et ben
ce serait lui donner un caractère trop
politique trop monochrome et donc à
partir de là une élection en deux fois à
l'origine avant les les années 2000 en
trois fois he on avait un renouvellement
partière un une élection par les grands
électeurs donc avec une couche de
représentation supplémentaire ça permet
d'avoir une assemblée modératrice qui
peut mettre un haut là en cas de bah de
grandes révolutions notamment
constitutionnell ouais c'est pas parce
que vous faites là une analyse qui est
historique mais tu es totalement
d'actualité quand on quand on voit
Stéphane mern comment ça se passe à
l'Assemblée nationale et comment ça se
passe au Sénat depuis un an la chambre
modératrice on y on y est en en plein
j'ai j'ai une question pour le le
journaliste comment vous couvrez une des
élections comme ça là on vient de voir
notre reportage c'est des élections qui
peuvent être passionnantes on voit les
élus qui sont voilà qui qui mouillent la
chemise il y a il y a plusieurs
départements
du du Grand Ouest qui sont concernés bon
c'est pas l'élection dont on parle le
plus dans les médias comment vous la
couvrez non c'est pas l'élection dont on
parle le plus pour une bonne raison
c'est qu'en fait les électeurs sont des
grands électeurs donc c'est un ACCP tout
à fait particulier ça se passe le
dimanche dans le dans le hclos des
préfectures c'est c'est c'est pas je
pense pas que ce soit une élection qui
passionne les foules en plus si vous
voulez le nous dans notre dans notre
territoire par exemple dans dans l'ouest
on a on a si départements concernés sur
sur 42 départements voilà c'est un c'est
donc du coup on va avoir une couverture
qui sera avant tout locale dans les
endroits où il se passe quelque chose
mais moi ce que je trouve intéressant
par rapport à ce qui vient d'être dit et
par rapport au Sénat c'est que euh
depuis le début du quinquena du premier
quinquena d'Emmanuel Macron le Sénat a
pris énormément d'importance dans la vie
politique française pour pour plusieurs
raisons la première c'est que
en en 2017 au moment de l'élection
d'Emmanuel Macron il y avait une espèce
de vague il gagne vous avez le
l'Assemblée nationale une déferland de
députés euh la République en marche et
on s'attendait à ce qu'il y ait une
entrée massive de sénateurs euh aux
élections de de de la de de l'automne
2017 ce qui s'est passé c'est
qu'entre-temps vous avez un un
gouvernement édard Philippe qui a braqué
de manière très spectaculaire les élus
locaux en prenant une série de de de de
mesures en fait avec une espèce de de
discours qui consistait à dire euh les
élus locaux c'est le vieux monde on pas
besoin cor intermédiaire pas besoin des
élus locaux et en fait ils ont raté
complètement cette élection ouais n
jamais réussi à r à rraper et et ce que
ce que je voulais dire simplement c'est
que ça a permis au Sénat à un moment où
les partis politiques étaient mis cul
par-dessus tête par l'élection
d'Emmanuel Macron qui était en pleine
déconfiture ça a permis au Sénat de
s'affirmer comme une force la première
en fait la première force d'opposition
politique en France et ce rôle est a été
encore renforcé après les dernières
législatives cell du printemps parce que
je ne sais pas si vous avz vous avez
remarqué mais autrefois dans le
processus législatif on commençait on on
commençait à étudier les projets de loi
au Sénat qu'avec des projets de lois qui
concernaient les territoires c'est plus
du tout ça qui se passe depuis la
rentrée c'estàd qu'il y a une espèce de
jeu qui consiste à à mettre les dossiers
sensibles au Sénat
d'abord ensuite les passer à l'Assemblée
donc le rôle du Sénat n'a jamais à mon
avis enfin ça faisait longtemps que le
rôle du Sénat n'avait pas été aussi
important et déterminant la vie
politique française que le Sénat a
changé statut quand même entre les deux
mandatures d'Emmanuel Macron d'une
chambre de contrôle et d'empêcheur de
tourner en rond dont par exemple
l'affaire benala est vraiment été
l'emblème à un changement de statut où
maintenant c'est un partenaire on le
sait il y a beaucoup de de ministres qui
ont trouvé les numéros des présidents de
groupe qui maintenant sont reçus quand
même très régulièrement tout a changé
quand même en terme d'ambiance le moment
où on n'avit pas un ministre qui venait
au Sénat pour s'exprimer et où
maintenant et bien on les voit beaucoup
plus traîner dans les couloirs donc
c'est aussi ça l'enu alors on y
reviendra sur cet aspect qui est
vraiment très intéressant de et
notamment les relations entre Emmanuel
Macron l'exécutif et euh les les
sénateurs sénatrices et puis plus
globalement on va dire les les élus
locaux mais on va faire un peu de
pédagogie vous l'avez compris dans dans
dans ce débat allez je vous donne
quelques infos le délai limite tiens
pour le dépôt des candidatures c'est le
8 septembre on y est presque hein faut
vous dépêcher si vous voulez vous
présenter 8 septembre 18h le jour de
l'élection j'ai déjà donné mais on va le
revoir ce jour parce qu'on sera
évidemment sur le pont notamment tous
les deux on sera en tion de la soirée
sera un grand plaisir on pr Anne à 16h30
si si je ne me trompe 21 voilà donc on
vous donne d'ors et déjà rendez-vous le
dimanche 24 septembre pour pour vous
donner les résultats de ces sénatoriales
un mandat ça dure un mandat sénatorial
ça dure 6 ans mais vous on va vous en
dire beaucoup plus grâce à Quentin calm
qui doit être juste derrière dans les
coulisses donc des élections Quentin qui
vont avoir lieu dans un peu plus de 2
semaine allez on démarre avec le mode de
scrutin qui est quand même bien
particulier ouais c'est vrai que Thomas
c'est c'est une élection très très
particulière avec un plus un mode de
scrutin complexe mais qui diffère en
fonction des départements on va y
revenir en tout cas depuis la dernière
révision constitutionnelle sur le sujet
au début des années 2000 le Sénat est
renouvelé par moitié tous les 3 ans et
vous le disiez pour un mandat de
sénateur de maintenant 6 ans et non plus
neu comme par le passé et au total cette
année ce sont 170 sièges de sénateurs
qui sont renouvelé dans certains
départements pas tous on va voir la
carte de France de l'élection sénateor
des élections sénatoriales du 24
septembre et c'est là que ça se
complique parce que et bien en fonction
de la taille du département s'il est
très peu PL ou pas vous avez deux modes
de scrutin différents en bleu vous voyez
les sénateurs sont élus au scrutin
majoritaire ce sont les départements où
on élit un ou deux sénateurs donc les
départements les plus ruraux on va dire
et dans les autres c'est un scrutin
proportionnel c'est-à-dire un scrutin de
liste parmi les départements qui
renouvellent le plus de sénateurs on
pense à Paris vous voyez est tout en
haut à droite avec 12 sièges à pourvoir
et cetera exactement mais aussi le nord
vous voyez c'est 11 sièges à côté du pas
decalis 7 et on voit en fait toute la
petite couronne et la grande couronne
sont renouvelables c'est donc
l'île-de-fance qui va et bien capter le
plus de sénateurs à renouvel je crois
que c'est 53 pour effectivement l'île
defance j'ai toujours rêvé de faire ça
il y a un côté Monsieur Météo regardez
bien le nord c'est ici avec le chiffre
11 qui est appeler aux urnes Quentin qui
élit les sénateurs ce sont les grands
électeurs Thomas il ont 78000 à être
appelés à voter le 24 septembre c'est un
vote obligatoire à 95 % ces grands
électeurs sont des conseillers
municipaux ou leurs représentants les
cinq autres pourents vous voyez ici ce
sont donc les les autres grands les
autres élus les conseillers
départementaux les conseillers régionaux
ou même les parlementaires mais on le
comprend tout se joue à l'échelon des
maires d'où le poids des dernières
élections municipales de 2020 qui vont
et bien donner forcément le résultat
qu'on aura le 24 merci beaucoup Quentin
pour pour tous ces détails je reviens
vers vous Lucile Schmith parce que c'est
c'est pas seulement des mathématiques
c'est ça qui est qui est intéressant
vous l'avez un peu évoqué tout à l'heure
mais euh bon il y a il y a parce que
sinon on dirait bon benah voilà ça voilà
les résultats des dernières élections
municipales c'est super simple voilà ce
qui va se passer aux prochaines
sénatorial c'est c'est pas que ça bah il
y a la question de au fond on se pose
beaucoup de vous évoquez 2017 Emmanuel
Macron Emmanuel Macron dit je dépasse la
gauche et la droite et on voit que au
Sénat la droite et la gauche n'ont
jamais été dépassé et ça a été rappelé
c'està-dire que au sénatorial d'après en
fait au fond elle confirme l'existence
des partis politiques mais par ailleurs
on a le sentiment qu'au Sénat se met en
place parfois notamment autour des
commissions d'enquête une culture de la
collaboration entre camps politiques
différents que ce soit sur l'affaire
benala vous le rappeliez mais aussi moi
je pensais à l'affaire des cabinets de
conseil à ce qui s'est dit sur minse que
je sache c'était pas des dangereux
gauchistes qui portaient la commission
d'enquête communiste et un LR voilà
intéressant souvent
desprésidésidor anagoni voilà et donc on
est dans cette situation où la droite
est la gauche non seulement coexiste
mais collabore même si on sait que le
Sénat restera clairement à droite et que
peut-être Gérard LCH et fort
probablement Gérard lâché devrait
redevenir président donc ça ça haôte un
petit peu de d'imprévu à l'élection qui
vient mais en tout cas ce qui est
intéressant c'est que autant à
l'Assemblée nationale vous le disiez au
fond la première quand même assemblée
Benjamin Morel le rappelait il y a eu
une élection au sctin majoritaire qui a
donné un résultat proche de la
proportionnelle ça on l'a plus tellement
il y a eu d'éclatement en fait mais ça
n'arrive pas à collaborer ça donne le
sentiment parfois d'une paralysie et du
coup le fait que le Sénat réussisse à
travailler correctement que le
gouvernement de plus en plus présente
ces textes en en première lecture au
Sénat ça donne au Sénat une position
très centrale et je voulais quand même
rappeler que Lionel Jospin lorsqu'il
était Premier ministre était avait au
fond dit il faudrait supprimer le Sénat
parce que c'est un truc complètement
obsolète dépassé et cetera on en est
très loin aujourd'hui mais ça signale à
mon avis au moins autant la crise de la
démocratie parlementaire et du
fonctionnement de l'Assemblée nationale
ouis Benjamin Morel le on évoquait tout
à l'heure le regard d'Emmanuel Macron
sur sur le Sénat il a il a forcément
changé depuis qu'il a plus de majorité
absolue à l'Assemblée nationale enfin il
y a il y a il y a un effet mécanique
tout simplement il y a un effet
mécanique et il y a un effet faut pas se
le cacher également un peu opportuniste
sous le premier quinquena cette chambre
en fait le seul contrepouvoir sous la 5e
République c'est-à-dire que comment
fonctionne la 5e République depuis le
quinquena vous gagnez l' lysée par effet
domino bah vous prenez l'Assemblée
nationale qui tient l'Élysée tient le
Palais Bourbon qui tient le Palais
Bourbon tient Matignon et donc ce
faisant il y a pas de contrepouvoir on
est le système politique dans lequel le
président de la République a a le plus
de pouvoir bien plus même que le
président des États-Unis dans son
système polique le régime présidentiel
au États-Unis c'est pres exactement le
Sénat a été sous de Gaul mais également
sousmeran et euh nager sous Emmanuel
Macron le seul contrepouvoir et en effet
ce contrepouvoir avec des forces
d'opposition certes contraire gauche et
droite mais qui malgré tout tout en
effet collabore et bien a joué à fond le
jeu du contrôle politique avec notamment
ses commissions d'enquête là on est dans
une autre situation le contre pouvoir se
situe également à l'Assemblée nationale
parce que il y a pas réellement de
majorité absolue et aujourd'hui vous
avez deux groupes qui dominent cette
chambre d'un côté la droite LR et Union
Centriste et de l'autre côté et bien les
socialistes or que vise Emmanuel Macron
et bien à construire des coalitions à
les élargir notamment en mordant sur sa
droite et en mordant sur sa gauche quand
il met des textes d'abord au sénatah il
espère que l'aval du groupe LR au Sénat
va entraîner par domino et bien l'aval
peut-être DLR à l'Assemblée nationale ça
marche pas t les ça ne marche pas à tous
les coups c'est pour ça exactement et
c'est pour ça qu'aujourd'hui ce calcul
initial n'est pas si évident néanmoins
bah au Sénat vous avez des groupes qui
tiennent vous avez un personnel
politique qui est relativement éprouvé
et en effet je dirais qui historiquement
est un peu mieux formé et donc se
faisant parier sur le Sénat plus que sur
ces majorités à l'Assemblée et ben ça
peut être un Paris payant donc le Sénat
qui est en effet le poil à gratter
aujourd'hui devient peut-être un recours
ouais vous avez évoqué les commissions
d'enquête je voudrais y revenir et et
entendre votre analyse de de de
journalistes parce que au sein des
rédactions il y a parfois ça coûte cher
d'ailleurs des de l'investigation est-ce
que vous vous dites que que le Sénat
travaille bien on n'est pas là pour
voilà c'est c'est vrai que le boulot ça
fait qui 2 ans et demi que je suis là
moi j'ai quand même était assez surpris
de du travail des qui était qui était
réalisé en en commission ces commissions
dans elles sont quoi complémentaires de
de travail d'investigation de certains
journalistes parfois elles déclenchent
un travail d'investigation comment vous
l'analysez ça vous parlez des
commissions d'enquête qui ont parce
qu'elles ont elles ont fait beaucoup
parler d'elle elles ont spectaculaire
oui c'est vrai et c'était
particulièrement intéressant mais il y a
pas que les commissions d'enquête quand
on parle du travail du Sénat moi ce que
je trouve ce que j'ai toujours trouvé
remarquable ce sont les rapports qui
sont faits par le Sénat si vous comparez
enfin excusez-moi mais si vous comparez
la qualité du travail et du rendu des
travaux des sénateurs avec ceux des des
députés oui j'ai envie de vous dire
c'est le jour et la nuit c'estd que le
le le le Sénat a l'habitude de
travailler en coopération en
collaboration en profondeur et ils
travaillent leur dossier de manière très
maîtrisée très technique et en fait il y
a pas que les commissions d'enquête oui
bien sûr n on fait souvent des débats en
s'appuyant sur sur ces Rapp ça je trouve
que c'est assez peu connu et c'est
dommage parce que vous avez vraiment des
choses qui sont très très pertinentes et
qui sont très éclairantes sur des des
grands des grandes questions de société
beaucoup plus beaucoup plus que qu'à
l'Assemblée toujours sur les commissions
d'enquête Luc Schmith on n'est pas non
plus naïf c'est un c'est un de de
politique notamment depuis le le le
premier quinquen Emmanuel Macron quoi
c'est la la la majorité au Sénat elle
décide de commission d'enquête parfois
pour aiguillonner on va dire Emmanuel
Macron c'est assez clair non mais ce qui
est intéressant si je reprends l'affaire
des cabinets de conseil moi ce que je
trouve intéressant c'est votre question
sur les journalistes c'estàdire qu'on
sait bien qu'aujourd'hui mener des
investigations c'est pas toujours
possible et que en tout cas le
journalisme d'investigation est en crise
ou en tout cas est considéré comme en
crise de longue date et du coup quand
quelque chose se passe dans les
institutions Laib possibité de relayer
ça d'y donner un autre regard c'est très
important et la question des cabinets de
conseil par exemple j'ai trouvé ça
extrêmement intéressant moi qui a une
formation de haut fonctionnaire parce
que cette question de qu'est-ce qui
relève du service public qu'est-ce qui
relève du privé la question du pro du
proonau enfin de de fait de donner de
donner des choses gratuitement pour
espérer ensuite avoir plus la question
du rôle fondamental joué par minse que
c'était mis à jour par le Sénat qui
l'aurait dit qui l'aurait pensé donc il
y a le sentiment qu'au fond une
institution elle trouve de la légitimité
lorsque quelque part elle surprend elle
s'aventure
d'arrièrepensé oui on s' fiche d'une
certaine manière parce que ce qui compte
c'est que notre vie démocratique soit
réactivée soit ressuscitée comme elle
donne le sentiment souvent de conflit
stéril le fait queon puisse s'intéresser
à des contenus donne un je trouve une
résonance beaucoup plus forte dans la
société Benjamin Mor est-ce qu'on peut
dire que c'est le signe d'une démocratie
en bonne santé des commissions d'enquête
parlementairire al alors la démocratie
ne va pas très bien aujourd'hui mais
elle va pas très bien partout en occid
question néanmoins c'est pas la faute du
Sénat et j'ais que le Sénat concourt
justement à une qualité aujourd'hui en
effet du travail politique et à la
démocratie de manière à ass essentiel
vous disez c'est politicien oui c'est
politicien mais si vous prenezot
d'illeurs c'est pas du tout un gros mot
parce qu'en réalité si vous considérez
la théorie de l'opposition souvent on
considère que ben il y a les
contrepouvoirs et le Parlement fait
contrepouvoir au à l'exécutif ça marche
pas comme ça aujourd'hui vous voyez bien
que la majorité parlementaire quand elle
est de la même couleur que le Président
de la République elle ne va surtout pas
critiquer le président de la République
avoir une chambre d'opposition qui va
chercher la petite bête parce qu'elle y
a un intérêt politicien et qui découvre
la petite bête et bien c'est comme ça
que s'exerce le contrôle c'est très
anglo-saxon en réalité en
Grande-Bretagne vous avez justement une
opposition et cette opposition a des
droits et c'est parce que l'opposition
est un petit peu et bien tatillon que la
majorité va bien se comporter c'est ce
qu'a fait le Sénat sous le premier
quinquenat d'Emmanuel Macron et en ça
bah il a mis sa petite pierre à la
démocratie bon on va pas faire semblant
dire qu'il y a un suspense de dingue sur
les les résultats de ces élections
sénatoriales non non mais je vais pas
vous demander de faire ça on va on être
d'accord la droite devrait conserver la
majorité au Sénat oui oui j'ai fait tout
ce que je pouvais he pourett un peu de
sexitude dans cette dans ce papier mais
ça c'est pas possible on n'attend pas
effectivement de cette élection un grand
bouleversement le Sénat c'est c'était ça
sera ça restera un bastion de la droite
après le 24 septembre prochain
R et ses alliés centristes vont
conserver la majorité absolue dans la
foulée on peut prévoir que Gérard
Larcher président incontesté depuis 2008
à l'exception d'une breve parenthèse
entre 2011 et 2014 et bien il sera réélu
sans doute une 5e fois voilà le résult
il est écrit d'avance la messe est
ditite l'dito est bouclé ah on s'arrête
là voilà non on va quand même parler des
autres groupes voilà d'abord les groupes
de gauche hein vous en avez parlé qui
partent plutôt Unis hein j'ai bien dit
groupe de gauche du Sénat pas nup
puisqu'il manque une composante
importante de laanup dans cette union
c'est LFI c'est un mastodonte national
et bien c'est un un local dont le reste
de la gauche n'a donc pas voulu pour
cette élection du coup les socialistes
qui sont tout de même le deuxè groupe du
Sénat les écologistes les communistes
ils ont conclu un accord début juillet
le résultat est bien des listes communes
dans 15 départements et comme on dit
l'union fait la force et donc la
division fait la défaite voilà partir en
ordre dispersé ça ne marche jamais dans
aucune élection les sénatoriales c'est
pas différent la majorité présidentielle
a lancé quelque chose puisque les
marcheurs eux et bien ils cumulent les
handicaps les élus ne sont pas très
nombreux ils sont 24 actuellement au
Sénat ensuite ils n'ont pas de ma les
dernières municipales de 2020 elles ont
été cat rique ça n'aide pas non plus
enfin il y a ce que l'on appelle
pudiquement des divergences stratégiques
c'està-dire bien sûr des dissidences des
dissidents qui contestent des sortants
dans les ivelines dans les hautes scènes
dans le Pas de calis bref ça pourrait
être la soupe à la grimace pour le
groupe de François patri alors est-ce
que ces élections sont aussi prévisibles
et bien il y a quand même une lueur
d'espoir pour voilà le groupe des
marcheurs c'est justement le cas
François patria c'est la preuve vivante
que les pronostiqueurs aussi informés
que nous tous sur ce plateau peuvent
magistralement se planter c'esttait qui
qui s'était passé en 2020 où François
patria était déjà annoncé comme mort et
enterré et bien il était allé chercher
sa victoire avec les dents 2 mois où le
marcheur historique avait pris son ball
son bâton de pèlerin ou plutôt à
l'époque son Opel de location orange
pour démarcher chaque maire de son fief
et se rappeler donc à son bon souvenir
et çaavait donc fonctionner et ce genre
de campagne elles peuvent fonctionné
d'autant que les élus locaux aujourd'hui
et bien ils sont de moins en moins
politisés de moins en moins partisans et
du coup même dans une même majorité
municipale vous pouvez avoir différents
votes de quoi rajouter tout de même
quelques inconnus dans les alors on on
l'a vu dans le reportage de d'audre
betaz et Jonathan du Priz la l'étiquette
majorité présidentielle peut jouer voilà
dans les deux sens c'est ça c'est voilà
c'est à double tranchant certains élus
locaux peuvent souhaiter avoir un
sénateur qui a ses entrées dans les
ministères qui pourra peut-être gagner
des arbitrages sur certains projets
locaux mais dans l'ensemble on l'a dit
Emmanuel Macron ce n'est pas du tout une
figure populaire auprès des Oliv depuis
la réforme de la taxe d'habitation voilà
Emmanuel Macron c'est donc le caillou
dans la chaussure des marcheurs mais ça
tout comme François Hollande en son
temps qui s'était mis les élus locaux à
dos avec sa réforme territoriale tout
comme Nicolas Sarkozi en son temps qui
avait provoqué une levée de bouclier
avec son conseiller territorial tout ça
n'est donc pas très nouveau un président
n'est jamais prophète dans les
territoires merci beaucoup Tam lucde
Schmith est-ce que un grand électeur et
là je m'appuie de nouveau sur votre
expérience attends un retour sur
investissement si j'ose dire est-ce
qu'il y a de ce côté donnant donnant euh
je vote pour toi mais tu vas porter les
les les arguments de mon territoire je
crois que ça dépend profondément de
votre territoire je pense que moi
j'étais dans les hautes scènes je crois
pas que j'attendais un retour sur
invessement mais je crois que dans un
département rural je pense que c'est
essentiel parce que le sentiment d'être
abandonné la question des gilets jaunes
qui reste un mouvement dormant la
question de la montée de la précarité le
sujet du Zéro artificialisation net qui
bouleverse beaucoup euh la question de
comment est-ce qu'on construit à un
moment où il y a une crise du logement
et une demande qui ne bouge pas du côté
des des des habitants je crois qu'il y a
une demande de logement donc au fond
tout dépend où vous êtes mais je crois
aussi que le retour sur investissement
peut être le fait que vous jouez un rôle
important ici euh et que cette question
d'être connu de porter des sujets
nationaux c'est aussi un point essentiel
moi je vous savez j'aime beaucoup
l'écologie je pense que quand quand on
est par exemple un grand électeur
écologiste je pense qu'on attend un
retour sur investissement qui n'est pas
forcément un retour local je pense qu'on
peut au contraire avoir envie que on on
bataille pour des sujets pour imposer un
plus haut niveau d'ambition donc tout
dépend au fond de qui vous êtes
également donc il faut croiser
différents critères où vous êtes qui
vous êtes est-ce que vous êtes par
exemple un plus jeune grand électeur
est-ce que vous êtes sensible à des
interrogations générationnelle est-ce
que vous faites partie de ces grands
électeurs que la vague relative mais
quand même une vraie vague de euh de
conquête de par les écologistes des des
des grandes villes euh donc on sait que
les écologistes vont faire sans doute un
meilleur score en tout cas qu' peuvent
l'espérer euh donc tout ça modifie sans
doute la physionomie du grand électeur
je crois pas qu'il y a de portrait robot
du grand électeur oui évidemment c'est
c'est forcément complexe on va parler de
la majorité LR ici au au au Sénat elle
va pouvoir euh Stéphane Vernet continuer
de quoi de d'aiguillonner Emmanuel
Macron peut-être par exemple tiens sur
la loi la loi immigration qu'est-ce que
vous en pensez ah ben moi je pense que
la loi immigration typiquement elle va
elle va être présentée au Sénat avant
d'être présentée à l'assemblée ça sera
fin octobre début novembre et a priori
euh
c'est exactement ce que je ce que je
vous disais tout à l'heure mais c'est
une façon aussi d'essayer de piéger les
les députés républicains euh à
l'Assemblée parce qu'ils sont
historiquement en fait ce sont deux
groupes ils sont dans la même famille
politique mais ils se sont jamais
beaucoup entendus en fait donc le fait
de commencer à la au au Sénat et
d'obtenir un vote positif sur ce projet
de loi qui va être très disputé très
très discuté au Sénat permettrait de
donner ça donne un argument
supplémentaire à la majorité
présidentielle pour essayer de faire
passer le texte ensuite à l'Assemblée
c'est ce que je voulais dire tout à
l'heure quand dans le dans le dans
l'inversion des des calendriers ce qui
se faisait pas du tout autrefois en fait
donc euh le ce que je peux vous dire
aussi sur les sur les républicains c'est
que en fait il y a 65 postes sur ce 65
sièges au sein des LR qui sont
renouvelables sur 145 et ce qui était
évoqué tout à l'heure notamment les les
écologies ce qui est intéressant en fait
si vous voulez c'est que dans les dans
les0 170 postes à à pourvoir euh
peut-être ce qu'il faut rappeler au
téléspectateurs c'est que vous avez un
poids des grandes villes où en fait le
le système de désignation des grands
électeurs quand vous avez une grande
ville vous dépassez largement vous avez
beaucoup plus de grands électeurs que
dans des toutes petites communes où il y
a un adjoint enfin bon bref un ou deux
grands électeurs pas plus et en général
on le nombre de grandes électeurs
déborde le le nombre de d'élus au
conseil municipal dans les dans les
grandes ville et là ce qui se passe
c'est que les conseils municipaux vont
choisir des gens qui sont connu pour
être des militants de la majorité de la
ville enfin voilà du personnel politique
ou des et donc on s'assure et ça ça peut
vous faire basculer un un vote et quand
vous avez un certain nombre de grandes
villes qui sont passées du côté des
écologistes au dernièr municipal ça peut
jouer sauf qu'en réalité là dans les
départements qui sont concernés en
septembre vous avez que l'indrloir par
exemple tour qui qui pourrait être
concerné vous avez Grenoble mais
Grenoble c'est Piol et de Grenoble
depuis 2014 donc il y aura il y aura pas
de bouger pas de gros bouger et en fait
d'autres villes qui qui ont basculé
comme Strasbourg sont pas concerné
Bordeaux n'est pas concerné Lyon n'est
pas concerné puisque les départements
sont pas sont pas renouvelables donc du
coup euh on peut se dire que oui il y a
une montée des écologistes même quand
ils ont pas gagné ben sauf que je je moi
je je pense que ça se traduira pas en
fait par une poussée je ne crois pas que
ça puisse se traduire par une poussée
spectaculaire et une entrée très forte
de nouveaux sénateurs très for on y
reviendra sera très faible on y
reviendra si vous le voulez bien au au
parti de de gauche ici au au Sénat mais
Benjamin Morel pourquoi le Sénat est à
droite depuis si longtemps je mets les
pieds dans le plat 5è 5e élection
annoncée de Gérard Larcher à la
présidence du du du Sénat c'est quoi
c'est le découpage c'est quoi ça a tout
à fait à voir avec ce que disait
Stéphane c'est-à-dire que vous avez une
sousreésentation des grandes villes en
réalité pourquoi bah parce que votre
conseil municipal il est limité en
nombre et donc au bout d'un moment vous
n'avez pas assez de membres du conseil
municipal pour voter 95 % encore une
fois CIT dit dans votre infographie des
élus qui vont voter pour les sénateurs
et bien sont des élus municipaux Mair et
conseillers municipaux donc qu'est-ce
que vous faites quand vous atteignez ce
plafond bah vous allez chercher des
délégués extérieur le problème c'est que
le Conseil constitutionnel a dit il faut
quand même pas pousser il faut que ce
soit limité il faut que la plupart de
ceux qui votent et quand même un mandat
démocratique donc est été élu donc on
peut rajouter quelques délégués
supplémentaires mais pas assez pour
équilibrer la démographie et donc vous
avez une surreprésentation pas tant des
petites villes en réalité mais des
communes moyennes des communes de 20
30000 habitants qui historiquement
votent plus à droite en revanche et bien
les grandes grandes villes Paris Lyon et
cetera elles sont structurellement sous
représentées et c'est là que la gauche
fait de bons scores donc pour cette
raison-là on a en effet un sénat qui
tire structurellement plus vers la
droite et qui historiquement et ben
n'est passé à gauche que 3 ans sous la
5e République et qui avant et ben
favoriser d'autres Parti de la Gauche
notamment le Parti radical parce que
mais c'était un parti qui était bien
implanté dans ses communes moyennes
alors il y a un autre enjeu de ces
élections sénatoriales du 24 septembre
l'éventuelle entrée de sénatrice ou
sénateur du rassemblement national je
rappelle qu'aujourd'hui le RN n'a aucun
représentant Stéphane Ravier qui était
le seul élu du parti de Marine Le Pen
ayant rejoint ERC Zemour et reconquête
lors de la la présidentielle alors sur
ce thème justement écoutez Marine Le Pen
sur cette absence des sénateurs RN
c'était il y a à peu près un an lors des
journées Parlement ire de son parti les
prochaines élections sénatoriales qui
auront lieu en 2023 corrigeront je
l'espère c'est uncenance démocratique
qui perdure au Sénat ce dénis
démocratique prive la Haute Assemblée
d'une part de sa nécessaire
représentativité et je le sais d'une
énergie nouvelle qui lui serait
grandement
profitable Stéphane Vern je reviens vers
vous est-ce que les résultats des
dernières élections locales laissent
augurer d'une entrée de alors je sais
pas combien mais quelques sénatrices ou
sénateur alors là-dessus je suis
incapable de vous répondre parce que
comme le disait tout très bien Tran tout
à l'heure c'est c'est le le la majorité
en fait des des élus locaux il ils ont
de moins en moins deétiqu politique et
plus ça va plus on avance dans le temps
plus c'est le cas et donc il y a une
espèce de il a il y a ce il y a ce
double cas c'est-à-dire qu'il y a on ne
sait pas vraiment quelle est la couleur
des uns et les autres parce que quand
vous y allez en disant liste de
rassemblement et cetera enfin sans
étiquette et là il y a il y a il y a il
y a une inconnue et l'autre aspect des
choses c'est que ce que disait très bien
Lucile schmidth au tout début c'est que
en fait c'est c'est aussi une élection
où au-delà d'étiquette la les
personnalités comptent énormément c'est
aussi pour ça que François patria euh a
échappé à la la la défaite à plus
campagne électorale la qualité de de la
campagne ça mais mais totalement
complètement et et donc on est dans un
enfin ça fait beaucoup si vous voulez on
est dans des contextes très différents
par rapport à par rapport aux autres
élections auxquelles on est habitué donc
donc il y aura peut-être quelques
quelques quelques sénateurs Ren mais je
pense pas qu'on assiste à une déérente
non plus effectivement on pense
vraisemblablement que ça sera très ENF
impossible qu'il y ait un groupe RN on
peut penser qu'il y a il y a des risque
dans le Pas de Calais par exemple ça
dépend aussi des dissiden ou de genre de
choses et puis peut-être on a un autre
sénateur actuellement c'est Jean-Louis
Masson très très proche de Marine Le Pen
et voilà lui on sait qu'il est très
proche de son de son territoire et par
exemple typiquement ce que vous disiez
c'est qu'il peutah convaincre un certain
nombre d'élus qu'il connaî très bien ça
peut donner un siège dans ces coinl et
puis lu schmi les élections locales ne
réussissent pas non plus au
rassemblement national quoi les les
municipales ça pas été une des ferantes
du RN oui mais je me disais aussi une
chose c'est qu'on parlait de l'état de
notre démocratie et ce qui est très
intéressant c'est que les trois
principaux candidats les ceux qui sont
arrivés en tête au fond à l'élection
présidentielle Emmanuel Macron Marine Le
Pen Jean-Luc Mélenchon ils ont pas
d'implantation locale en fait c'est très
intéressant c'està-dire que notre
démocratie elle a des types d'élection
extrêmement différentes et en fait on a
cette élection sénatoriale qui je trouve
dans son style dit quelque chose sur une
je dirais une démocratie plus humaine en
fait cette question de comment on
discute réellement comment on aborde les
questions de contenu et cetera ce qui
est jamais le cas dans une législative
moi j'ai fait plusieurs législatives on
avait votre affiche on vous dit j'espère
que votre photo est bien et puis et puis
on a l'élection présidentielle où pour
le coup il y a des débats de contenu et
cetera mais ça n'applique pas la
question locale et du coup il y a une
démocratie éparpillée où on forme puzzle
et au fond comment est-ce que tout ça va
converger pour donner le sentiment que
la démocratie fonctionne bien c'est un
point essentiel il suffit pas ensuite
que le Sénat discute bien dans le cadre
de de de son hémicycle et cetera comment
aussi est-ce que les sénateurs prennent
vraiment leur place et comment est-ce
que c'est pas en permanence ça a été dit
un dialogue de Sour entre président de
la République et élus locaux ouais mais
Marine Le Pen on vient de l'entendre
elle parle d'inconvenance démocratique
est-ce qu'on peut pas considérer
effectivement que c'est une je sais pas
quel terme employer inconvenance que
vous nous l'avez dit les trois
principales forces politiques en tout
cas à la présidentielle soi si peu ou
sous représenté pas ou sous- représenté
au Sénat ça a tout à fait à voir avec la
première question que vous m'avez posé
le Sénat en fait est une sorte de
conservateur de la vie politique
autrement dit il y a en règle générale
20 ans de retard entre la montée d'une
puissance politique au niveau national
et sa traduction au Sénat l'égolistes
ont mis 20 ans à s'implantter dans les
collectivités territoriales et avoir un
groupe substantiel au Sénat ils seront
pas en réalité majoritaire dans la
droite sénatoriale avant les années 80
d'autres forces je parlais tout à
l'heure du Parti radical qui étaient
marginalisé au niveau national sont
restés très très longtemps les forces
majeures au Sénat c'est ça a pour but en
fait de dire bah voilà il y a des
élections ces élections et bien elles
ont donné une vision du paysage
politique mais ce n'est pas forcément
une vision structurelle la vision
structurelle elle est plutôt incarnée
par le Sénat après on peut avoir
quelques scénateur RN en plus il y a au
moins deux facteurs qui le permettrai
d'abord il y a une grande grande
division cette année des listes ce soit
droite comme à gauche et ça évidemment
dans les départements à la
proportionnelle ça peut favoriser des
élus RN ensuite il y a quand même eu
quelque chose aux dernières législatives
aujourd'hui vous avez beaucoup de petits
maires non inscrits et cetera qui se
disent que Ben le député RN ils n'ont
pas forcément de mauvais rapport avec
lui et que donc avoir un élu RN avoir
qui plusé une grande partie de sa circo
qui a voté rassemblement national et
bien ça peut désinhiber certains votes
donc on aura pas de Ras de Maré on aura
probablement pas de groupe je parle là
de quelques sénateurs RN supplémentaires
mais il en effet quelque chose qui se
passe et encore une fois quand on prend
l'histoire sur le long terme bah c'est
quelque chose d'assez naturel ouais euh
ces élections sénatoriales elles vont
ell laisse déjà des des traces à gauche
les partis déjà représenté au au Sénat
on l'a évoqué PS Europe Écologie é ver
et PC ont donc travailler pour parvenir
à un accord écoutz la secrétaire
nationale d'Europe et collégire Marine
Tondelier alors c'était avant l'accord
on était au au mois de juin dernier dans
la matinale on y travaille disait-elle
moi je ça me paraît trit normal de
travailler avec le Parti communiste et
le Parti socialiste sénatorial c'est pas
simple partout je ne désespère jamais
vous avez remarqué donc je pense qu'on
va les discussions Luc C accord il a
fini par aboutir sans LFI on l' on l'a
bien compris au grandam de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon là aussi on l'a bien entendu
il décolèr pas de depuis les élections
européennes d'ailleurs du 9 juin
prochain vont certainement pas le calmer
est-ce que il a pas un peu raison d'être
en colère même si c'est un de ses traits
de caractère le plus récurrent Jean-Luc
Mélenchon non sur cette élection c'est
évident que l'Union ion permettra au
moins de maintenir un groupe enfin des
groupes qui sont déjà minoritaires donc
le sujet c'est au fond comment est-ce
que la gauche continue à exister et par
ailleurs comme on l'a dit comme au Sénat
il y a cette tradition de coopération
moi je pense que c'est très bon pour la
gauche d'avoir fait ça après je
comprends que Jean Mélenchon soit pas
content mais je ne suis pas sûr que ce
soit fondamental pour aurait été plus
forte avec LFI en son non je pense pas
parce que le sujet on l'a dit c'est le
sujet des grands électeurs et comme fi a
très peu de grands électeurs la question
c'est plutôt en faisant ça est-ce que on
ne s'interdit pas enfin dans en tout cas
dans les dans dans les les territoires
dans les départements où il y a une
liste à la proportionnelle d'élargir sur
le centre moi j'ai vu par exemple dans
les hautes scènes où la gauche était
extrêmement faible
l'élection d'un sénateur écologiste qui
a réussi à attirer à lui des des grands
électeurs du centre donc évidemment ça
fige le rapport de force euh bon mutatis
mutandis que ce que disait Benjamin
Morel sur la question des dissidences il
y a pas mal de dissidences aussi à
gauche et donc il faudra voir comment
les dissidences à gauche haute ou pas
euh des voix à ces listes qui sont des
listes d'union parce que la liste
d'union ça crée beaucoup de problèmes du
côté de certaines personnalités parce
que comme on l'a dit il faut à la fois
assumer que c'est une élection où les
personnalités jouent beaucoup et par
ailleurs si on fait une liste d'union on
fait une liste plus idéologique donc il
y a souvent une conflictualité entre les
personnalités rayonnantes qui dépassent
leur camp et le fait de faire une liste
d'union qui signale le camp mais quand
même je reste sur l'anupè Stéphane
Vernay sénatorial puis européenne ce
voilà euh cette union peut-être survivre
à deux élections sans union vous voyez
ce que je veux dire moi je le pense la
problématique de de la la laanupes et la
la survie de l'anupes c'est la façon
dont Jean-Luc Mélenchon va se placer et
les partenaires de la les différentes
composantes de laanupes se placent
vis-à-vis de de Jean-Luc Mélanchon vous
voyez bien que le conflit il est à ce
niveau-là ou qui est pas d'accord il il
y a quand même en fait le les accords
pour les sénatoriales ils sont à la
carte c'est une quinzaine de département
euh c'est la réale politique qui prime
il y a vous l'avez dit il y a pas
d'ancrage de la France soumis dans les
territoires c'est pas vrai il y en a pas
donc il y a pas de grands électeurs donc
en fait a rien à gagn mais non au
contraire donc voilà il y a c'est un
principe de réalité de réalisme ils ont
ils ont pas tort et il il il il le
présentent et il l'annonce comme ça et
ils ont raison de le faire à Paris ils
peuvent ils peuvent il y a il y a je
pense qu'à Paris notamment ils peuvent
cette alliance entre PS PC et et vert
peut ils peuvent ils peuvent faire un
coup ils peuvent avoir ils peuvent ils
peuvent truster un un bon paquet des des
12 des 12 sièges ils peuvent ils peuvent
en espérer voire 10 ou et il y a selon
toute vessemblance il y aura un Yannick
jado par exemple qui qui va va rentrer
au sén persuadé mais Bonou mais mettez
un peu de
suspense rien n'est fait voà c'est
ça n'est jamais joué d'avance et pour
les européenne on est dans un autre mode
de scrutin et cetera on est dans dans
une dans une configuration complètement
complètement différente et moi je je je
je ne pense pas que le fait qu'il nit
pas de l commune aux européenes l'année
prochaine euh soit de nature à à faire
voler en éclat le le le l'anupes de
toute façon le principe c'est que là où
tous sont d'accord c'est de dire il y a
la nécessité de présenter un candidat
d'union de la gauche en 2027 h et le
vrai problème c'est de savoir qui allez
un tout dernier mot un tout dernier mot
juste par rapport à ça parce que les
européennes c'est un tour à la
proportionnelle toute la question c'est
comment ça peut rebattre le rapport de
force qui était très favorable à LFI et
si par exemple la liste LFI qui pour
l'instant est crédité d'un meilleur
score que les autres se retrouent à
avoir un moins bon score ça réouvrira
les choses merci à tous c'était
passionnant de de de vous entendre et
d'en savoir plus voilà sur le ces
élections sénatoriales prévu le 24
septembre d'ailleurs si vous voulez vous
aussi en savoir plus rendez-vous sur
notre plateforme
publicsenat.fr dossier élection
sénatoriale très complet qui a été
réalisé par la rédaction web de Public
Sénat les enjeux nationaux les batailles
par circonscription plein d'article
pédagogique sur le fonctionnement de ces
élections je rappelle les titres de vos
livres Emmanuel Macron à contre-emploi
c'est aux éditions Bayard lucide Schmith
et puis ce déjeuner secret il y en a eu
plusieurs après he dans les coulisses de
la réforme des retraite ça paraît demain
aux éditions wouest France à très
bientôt merci encore d'avoir participé à
ce débat la matinale de Public Sénat ben
elle elle va prendre possession des
lieux lundi matin ils vont avoir le
plaisir de de travailler aussi dans ce
nouveau décorement signer son équipe
reçoiv Olivier du SOP ministre du
Travail comme premier invité ce sera à
8h du matin merci Tam pour cette
première cé un bonheur et à très vite
sur ce plateau belle soirée sur public
C